uh we also have young Don we we wish
good for him
in it she reads the part where it says
Jesus
top 10 reasons why Jesus is not God
Jesus said me and the father are one
okay but then he also told the disciples
that me the father and all of you are
one he's trying to psych himself up
that's exactly why he couldn't be God
because it was sent for Andrew Tate yes
snico and young Don and for everybody
else
greetings of Peace welcome to the dean
show exciting episode with an exciting
guest an exciting topic and
you got to guess who's in the dean show
Studio my brother your brother Shake
it's man Farooq how are you doing
how you been how you doing alhamdulillah
spending some time here in Chicago
seeing you and uh working on the dean
Center inshallah a great project I'm
really excited we ask Allah to accept it
and increase it we've been told
streets to ask Americans about Islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all right that's
what you've been told that Muslims are
out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America we have 500 000 left and we need
your help to finish click to donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
foreign
thank you so much and I said exciting
talk topic that we're going to be
talking about I just want to give a
little bit of a background because you
have a very intriguing very touching
story of how you actually came to where
you're at today and just in a nutshell
before we get into the individual that
we're going to be talking about
Jesus peace be upon them peace I want to
know like um like why is this Muslim
talking about Jesus but you are someone
who is going to the church at one point
you know knowing more than the pastor
you know because you were asking
questions they couldn't answer and you
got very almost to a point of that I I
think you you could have been uh the
pastor at the at the church you know
it's funny because uh growing up I
didn't go to the Masjid I didn't know
Muslims uh all my friends were either
Catholic or Christian or some
denomination of Christianity and I used
to go to church with them
um I've been to every single type of
church you can imagine uh from Kingdom
Halls to uh any Catholic churches
southern baptist churches and I used to
actually pay attention I I used to love
to learn and the Bible that you see with
me and a lot of the dawa videos the
brown covered one I've had that since
that time so people think that I went to
the Bible just to debate but that's not
true I I wanted to learn but I found a
lot of things that didn't make sense or
things that didn't fit and I would ask
the pastors and I went through the whole
Bible cover to cover I mean I've got
highlights routing I took notes into it
I put stickies and the pastors many
times would get upset because they
wouldn't know and they would instead of
giving me an answer they would just kick
me out so I've been kicked out of a lot
of churches
but I kept going back to different
churches and learning because I always
wanted to know the truth so I've done a
good amount of studies in the Bible yes
now there was interesting story that you
shared with me was it a preacher Pastor
someone in the church older man who was
someone who saw some of your work and
some of your dialogues that you've had
and then you gave some evidence from the
Bible and again this is not to go ahead
and put down any religion or to no we
love Jesus I mean that's a fact yes you
know and this is we want good for
Humanity so this is not like hey we got
one on you we're trying to you know put
anybody down or anything but we're just
trying to relay you know a simple clear
message that the same message that Jesus
spoke and brought to the People based on
evidence and proof so now you did that
and this what was he a pastor who's a
pastor he saw this and what happened
alhamdulillah he's somebody 50 plus
years in the church 50 plus years in the
church yeah
Pastor 50 plus years yeah he taught the
Bible one of your videos yeah he is I
think he's around 70 something years of
age and he got hold of some of the
videos and per his message that I was
showing you
um at first he didn't like it because
you know sometimes when we educate
people and they come from a mindset they
take it as a shock and especially if we
have any Christians watching uh I want
them to understand that we come from a
place of love we want guidance for
everybody we want good for everybody and
just as Jesus brought the message of the
one Creator who sent Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him and we love Jesus
so much that you will notice that even
when me or you mention his name we send
peace and blessings be upon him you'll
see for example some people like we had
a gentleman from Israel that came to our
table recently and you can see the video
and we asked him what do you think about
Jesus and Christians and he called
Christianity occult and he called Jesus
very inappropriate names as the faith
that he follows believes but we as
Muslims we love Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him we believe he was
a person who brought the truth we
believe he was born miraculously We
Believe believe that Mary was a virgin
this was a miraculous birth this is our
belief and our belief as many
historians have said is closer to the
true original followers of Jesus peace
and blessings be upon Him their belief
than Christians today and I encourage
other people to research for example
there's a Dr Bart ehrmann who's an
atheist today or agnostic atheist but he
is one of the top authorities he was a
Christian on the Bible in the history of
the Bible an early Christian traditions
and I have a video from him where he
talks about this he says the early
Christian
followers of Jesus peace and blessings
be upon him that were around him did not
consider him God
they took him to be a prophet somebody
who brought a message but did not
worship him as a god until the Council
of nicer this was not standardized there
were those before the Council of naziah
that took this View and there were
others there's a group called The Aryans
not nothing to do with the race it's
actually a Christian group and others
who did not consider Jesus to be a God
or the Son of God this is part of the
history this is part of History yes it's
all there and they're documented books
that have been right now making this up
no as I said Dr Bart Ehrman is not a
Muslim we don't claim he's a Muslim and
others not just him that have talked
about this so it's kind of like when you
get that injection that shot that's
supposed to be of some type of medicine
it's a sudden jolt yeah kind of Joseph
this is a jolt of truth yes but if you
let it sink in let it do its right
process think about it you know pray to
God Almighty alone and meant like many
have like this person didn't this pastor
end up accepting he accepted Islam
um his wife is still a Christian
um accepted Islam did he become an Arab
he's an American he's an American yeah
in fact neither one of us has ever be
there you know Islam has nothing to do
with any ethnicity obviously the
majority of the Muslim world is not Arab
I think around 14 is Arab but the rest
of the
86 is uh non-arabs the largest Muslim
country a population-wise Indonesia and
alhamdulillah in America us who are
Americans as well we we are Muslim as in
America we have no ties to any ethnicity
um he is a Muslim today that Pastor not
just him we've had many if you watched
the one message Foundation Channel you
will see different pastors and preachers
who watched our videos who came out and
they approached us and many of them
accepted Islam we've even had
conversations with Unitarian Christians
who till today do not believe in a
trinity this is still today Christian
segment that's out there so we one are
Christian viewers to know that this
Narrative of the Trinity and Jesus being
God and also the Son of God and maybe
God and the son this has not been The
Narrative of Christianity throughout
history this is something that was
invented a lot of pagan ideas God and
Zeus and Hercules and all this stuff has
been brought into Christianity Eddie I'm
gonna I'm gonna drop a a truth bomb here
right another injection
if you're a Christian and you're
watching I want to ask you a question
and this is a rhetorical question I want
you to ask yourself
do you celebrate Christmas
where do you think Christmas came from
you think it's in the Bible do you think
the 25th of December is in the Bible you
think Santa Claus and reindeer and
eggnog and these Christmas trees if you
read your Bible
there's actually verses that condemn
putting gold on trees and this type of
practice
These Are pagan
festivals saturnalia was a pagan Idol
worshiping Festival that was brought
into Christianity I challenge our
Christian viewers to research this on
your own this is this is a a want for
you to know the truth on your own Google
it I'm trying to show them you're better
than them
you know I'm not condemning anybody I'm
not saying I'm better I'm not saying I'm
more knowledgeable I'm not saying any of
that I'm saying I believe that there's a
lot of sincere Christians who want to
know the truth who want to believe in
God as he they should and I want them to
open their mind and read and look this
up on their own nothing to do with me
not for debate not for viewers nothing
of that and see that your churches have
been promoting Christmas a pagan
Festival in every household they have
these festivals in churches their
churches next to my house they have
Christmas trees they light these lights
up when this has nothing to do with
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him
and then think to yourself what other
Pagan Traditions have been brought into
the religion that you think is the
religion of Jesus
we can go on I mean look at Easter and
the Bunny and the eggs and where these
things came from I want to get into
Jesus peace be upon who we love
and you can't be a Muslim you can
actually get yourself a free one-way
ticket to the Hellfire as a Muslim If
you deny Jesus that is true now tell me
before I get into what I really want to
talk about Jesus who's beloved to almost
2 billion Muslims in the world today if
you are because they're hearing these
words Islam Muslim but if you were to do
like a taste test right and you were you
were putting a label on it and you just
to blindfold someone say hmm taste this
taste this but if you put in certain
labels on it then even while someone's
tasting it if they attribute in their
mind something negative to it then they
might even forget about how good it
tastes that is true so do you see that
now when people because there's so much
garbage thrown out there so many lies
and deception on this term Muslim so a
lot of times if you just Define the word
you didn't even say Muslim but you and
you would Define it Muslim you define it
find it and then you define what a
Christian is or Hindu do you think any
god-conscious person would pick this
definition that
is what you and me are and what we're
inviting them to Islam and to be a
Muslim you know to be one who is
submitted to the will of God of course a
Muslim comes from the word aslama that
is the root word for it which is to
submit a Muslim is the one who does that
they submit their will to their creator
and that's why we believe Jesus was a
Muslim by the definition of the word We
Believe Abraham Moses all the way from
Adam to the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings upon all of them were Muslims
they all did the will of the Creator
they submitted themselves in fact even
if Christians read the Bible you will
find that Jesus says that it's not my
will it's the will of my father the Lord
but if a Christian says well that's what
a Christian is excellent so if you look
at the word Christian look at the
definition it means the followers of
Christ and before Jesus Christ there was
no word Christian there were no
Christians because by definition they
could not be without Christ how would
you have Christians but the word Muslim
is not not tried to the prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon Him rather
the word Muslim is Aslam in the Quran in
the holy book of Islam you will find
Abraham peace and blessings be upon him
talking about them being Muslim so we
believe and we can prove through the
definition of the word that all of the
earlier prophets were Muslim but if you
take the word Christian you cannot say
that Moses was a Christian there was no
Christ so you cannot link that
definition one who submits consciously
to the creator of the heavens and earth
along without any Partners Associated to
God's will you cannot link that to any
other religion or of course any other
word exactly if you look at Judaism you
cannot and if you look at Judaism come
from the word Judah before Judah there's
no Judaism if you look at Christianity
comes from the word Christ even if you
look at other philosophies like
Shintoism or if you look Confucianism
come from Confucius before Confucius
there's not Buddhism from Buddha before
Buddha no Buddhism but Islam has been
that True Religion since the time of
Adam peace and blessings be upon him
till the day of judgment that one
message and if you look at the Ten
Commandments you will find that as the
religion of Islam hear o Israel your
lord is one what do we say in Islam
that Allah is say that Allah is one same
message that was brought by Abraham
Moses Jesus Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon all of them we as Muslims love
all the prophets you will never see a
Muslim disrespect any of them you never
see a Muslim make a cartoon of the
Prophet Jesus peace and blessings be
upon him or to mock him even when other
Christians and atheists and others they
mock the prophet Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him we as Muslims
condemn that you've never ever seen have
you any a Muslim making a caricature of
Jesus to mock Jesus peace and blessing
be upon him we as Muslims of the Quran
tells us we make no differentiation
between the prophets we believe in all
of them equal fully so if me as a Muslim
if I didn't believe in Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him as a true prophet
of God I will no longer be a Muslim
that's deep it's easy to understand
simple and hopefully that truth
injection you know wake somebody up all
right so let's get into this you think
you can come up we've done this before
do you think we can come up with Shake
's top 10 reasons why Jesus is not God
or the Son of God you think we'll give
it a shot no prep work here we haven't
prepared this this is going to be all
off the cover if we went from number 10
and you're talking to our sincere you
know our neighbors out there people who
have love for because Prophet Muhammad
is it correct he said God Almighty Allah
is saying that he was sent as a mercy to
all mankind yes Allah sent the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
as Mercy for all of mankind for all of
the creation not just a mercy for the
Muslims and that's why we say that The
Message of Islam is for everybody it's
not for Arabs only it's not for
pakistanis or Indonesians or Malaysians
or Saudis this is for everybody we do
not say any race is superior to another
the prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him told us that the Arab and
the non-arab the white the black they're
all equal none are better than the other
except Whoever has more piety Whoever
has more God Consciousness than because
of their good characteristics they can
raise the ranks but race has nothing to
do with it
so this is very straightforward very
clear we're going to get into now
because some people are on the fence
many people are confused they're like
okay God the father Jesus Holy Ghost and
here come the Muslims saying only one
God pray to the god of that Jesus prayed
to and now let's get some clarity here
let's start with number 10 and we'll go
work our way down
number 10
um from my own study and I have in my
personal Library I have a section that
has uh Bibles Christian literature
MacArthur Study Bible for example and so
on and I have a section that has books
that have to do with Judaism and the
study of the Old Testament according to
Jewish Scholars and in that I have never
found any mention of Jesus peace and
blessings be upon Him explicitly before
his time meaning if you look at the Old
Testament and yes there are Christians
that will try to make references into
things in the Old Testament but those
earlier Scholars before the time of
Jesus the commentaries that have been
orally written and then orally preserved
and then written by Jewish Scholars have
never found any reference to Jesus
before his time peace and blessings be
upon him so if he was God if God was a
trinity if God was not one then we would
have found a reference explicitly
through the trinity in the old documents
and we do not we find instead a emphasis
on their monotheism only one God not
three in one not two in one just one God
we find no explicit statement about
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him in
the Old Testament now you can say God
had his word and that but then again all
the biblical Scholars of the past Jewish
Scholars explained that that this is not
a reference to Jesus so if Jesus was God
then he would have always been God God
doesn't become God at a certain time so
number 10 is no reference to Jesus
before his time
okay
um let's go on to number nine number
nine
I don't believe God is born out of the
womb of a woman that if you look at the
greatness of God and if you look at the
might and glory of God to me and again
this is my own opinion uh I don't see
that this is befitting the creator of
the universe the ever living everlasting
all-knowing God that
he breastfeeds you know or you know pees
on himself as a child would would again
you can't have a square circle right
Eddie
um I really want our Christian tall
short man I mean let me just use this
example and I want our viewers who are
Christians to understand we're saying
this as out of love for you for to guide
to be a means that you wake yourself up
and just think through this this is not
a debate this is not to put anybody down
just take a moment pause the video if
you want and just contemplate this can
you have a square circle
by definition if it has Corners it
cannot be a circle
and if it has no edges it cannot be a
square we don't say that you God can't
do then God can do anything but when you
have something by definition that
doesn't match it just can't be infinite
and finite exactly right two totally
different so if according to the Bible
itself and you can look up your Bible I
mean I didn't prepare verses here but
you can look it up God is the knower of
everything yeah and God is all capable
and all God can is all-powerful
you cannot be all capable all-powerful
all-knowing and uncapable and then learn
the Bible you know there is a little
video of a little girl a Christian
household and she's she's reading a
little Christian book and she says you
know uh in it she reads the part where
it says
God how can you learn more and more
about himself
because Jesus is God
uh Jesus learned about God that's a
little girl she met the little girl
maybe you can add the clip
and that's amazing this is called her
her Natural State teachers question
exactly it's a great question so how can
you learn more and more about himself
because it said
grew up he learned more and more about
God his father
well exactly she as a little child
understood that if he was God then how
would he learn about himself he would
know himself he wouldn't need to read
about himself right so to me to say that
if it if if a child is born not knowing
anything if that child urinates on
himself what children do I've got
children I have no uh issue with you
know understanding that those are things
that naturally children they breastfeed
they go through you know diarrhea other
thing but that is not something that I
can attribute to the almighty creator of
the universe yeah that's I mean Square
Circle you can go on with this
all-powerful powerless you know these
are opposites you can't be at the same
time exactly uh number eight number
eight
when I look at the Bible and I've
studied the Bible cover the cover with
different types of Christians I see that
Jesus prayed to the father right and I'm
going to make this two different ones
one is that he supplicated meaning he
was asking of the father
so if Jesus was God and according to
Christians that I have spoken while on
Earth he was fully God they claim that
they were co-equal meaning him and the
father are equal and they are and he is
fully God then why would God be be
asking of somebody else why is he
praying himself exactly and we never
find the father praying to Jesus
he's trying to psych himself up
that's exactly why he couldn't be God
because God doesn't need to psych
himself up
so when you look at his supplications
like or you know the father take this
ball away from me
um you know why have you forsaken me and
so on and so on him supplicating to the
father it obviously shows that he was in
need of the father and that would mean
that he is not God beautiful I mean this
is just common sense it is it doesn't
make a take a lot of mental gymnastics
where you gotta you know it's very
simple you're trying to your mind
spinning trying to make it simple and
it's something that as Christians as as
atheists as agnostics and whatever
background you may be it will feel right
in your heart to say that God doesn't
pray to a co-equal God if that was true
then the father should also pray to
Jesus then the Holy Ghost should pray to
Jesus I don't know where the Holy Ghost
is in this picture I mean you look at
usually he's not even mentioned in a lot
of the verses
um and I'm going to go to the next one
what number are we on seven seven we're
going through this pretty quick number
seven is that Jesus put his forehead on
the ground he put his face he fell on
his face
praying to God
to the father according to their Bible
now if you're a Christian and you read
this verse think it through first thing
I want you to think about is who do you
see praying like Jesus today putting
their forehead on the ground take a look
just type in uh online Muslim muslims
praying right you will see muslims
praying as your Bible which you have a
claimed to shows that Jesus prayed that
way he fell on his face he put his face
on the ground and he prayed and in your
own Bible if you go in the Old Testament
you will also find Moses and Abraham and
other peace and blessings be upon all
the prophets praying in that way I have
been to many different churches and I
have seen everything from singing choirs
and Hallelujah and jumping up and down
and speaking in tongues I have yet to
see a Christian congregation regularly
pray in the way that Jesus prayed I've
had some Christians tell me that there's
a certain sect of Christians that pray
this way I keep hearing that I've heard
that right but I've never seen this I've
seen it yeah and why is not every sect
frame like that if that's what the Bible
says Jesus did so I don't believe that
God puts his head on the ground and
prays to God right the earlier one was
supplicating here it's praying so when
you see Jesus praying to the father as
his reference in your Bible then
obviously the father or God here is the
one that deserves to be worshiped and
Jesus worships him
I don't believe God worships God that
doesn't make any sense does that make
sense to you absolutely not if you're
honest with yourself
and you're sincere you would say the
truth and the truth so set you free so
tell the truth to yourself that's the
worst when you do cover lie you don't
cover up the truth so number we're going
through this quickly fairly quickly
let's get through them all six number
six in the Bible we find the devil Satan
tempts Jesus
I don't believe God gets tempted
humans get tempted yes even Pious people
get tempted righteous people get tempted
because humans have that weakness you
know
in the Quran that Allah created in San
IFA with in the state of weakness humans
have weaknesses we get tempted we have
desires we have shortcomings that is
true God the almighty the creator of the
universe does not get tempted
God cannot be tempted by Satan and if
Christians were to come back and say
that at that time he was in his human
form then we would say that if you say
that that means he was no longer God
can't have a square circle either you
can be tempted or you cannot be tempted
you can't be both you can't be both you
can't make God into like a Superman yeah
it's like he's stopped he's God he's got
a switch turns it on and offer yeah
number five number five we're getting to
the fun ones now
if we look at the Bible and the
narrative that Christians put forward
Jesus is killed and we as Muslims do not
believe that the prophet Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him was killed but
this is what Christians say then I would
say that cannot be God because God
cannot be killed he is all living ever
living
if you could kill God and just think
about this wouldn't you be more powerful
than God if you can overpower me then
obviously you're stronger than me
and if people killed God look at what
kind of a sin that would be how could
that be a means of forgiveness I don't
believe God can be killed and I had a I
had a debate you can watch the you the
one message Foundation Channel where in
two sentences we finished the Christian
debate the first question was
is God ever living can he be killed they
said no God can't be killed he's ever
living second question was was Jesus
killed they said yes so then Jesus can't
be God if he's ever living and cannot be
killed then Jesus couldn't be killed and
if you think Jesus was killed if that's
the Christian doctrine then it
contradicts what they just said he
cannot be killed and if the idea is that
he was killed but he was going to come
back to life anyway then where's the
sacrifice you know if I knew that you
know there's like a movie if I kill you
you're going to come back in the next
episode you're not really sacrificing
anything then right so that Doctrine
doesn't make sense to me I don't believe
God can be killed
makes no sense who's running the world
you can just go on with this you know
what I mean right um and it goes back
into Infinite finite give me just
unpackages this you know and just keep
running with it let's go number four
number four
if we look at the biblical
Narrative of Jesus we find that Jesus
was betrayed and when he was betrayed
and taken by the Romans he requested God
to take that away from him oh God like
my to the father to take this bull away
from him he wanted to be freed from that
punishment and even on the cross
according to Christians he asked God or
the Creator the father according to
biblical terminology that why have you
forsaken me you know he wanted to be
taken off the cross he wanted to be
taken off so that tells me even in what
they present as Christians that could
not be God if the idea is that Jesus
came to this world to be killed if that
was the plan then why would he want that
punishment taken away then that was the
plan then you should be like hey God you
haven't forsaken me this is the plan and
if he's telling God you've forsaken me
that's his mission if that's his mission
is he questioning the mission now
exactly so if the mission was to to be
crucified for the sins of mankind then
that's the plan then he should have been
happy with it statement contradicts that
exactly yeah and if he's asking for this
to be taken away from him if he doesn't
want this and if he was God then he
could do it himself too he could walk
away from it
but the fact that he was against this
moving in that direction shows to me
that according to the Christian
narrative he could not be God
where that was number four right that
was number four so we got three left
three left here we go all right let's go
number number three
I believe that God is one and if you
look at the Old Testament if you look at
the uh earlier scriptures and even if
you look at the New Testament and you
look at all of the references towards
the Ten Commandments we find a reference
to one God
now some Christians may come back with
some ambiguous verses right they may
come back and say Jesus said me and the
father are one okay but then he also
told the disciples that me the father
and all of you are one
right in the same Bible that the
Christians put so if they were to take
that that means Jesus is a part of God
then that would mean the disciples are
all God for example me and uad we might
say we're one nation like you know we
say one nation under God for example
does that mean you are the same or does
that mean you're on the same page we're
doing the same mission right for example
we as a we as a country we share some
values we have the Constitution we have
these things so we say we are one nation
but that doesn't mean we're the same
people we're we you're an individual I'm
an individual you have your own
characteristics I have my own you have
your own shortcomings and good qualities
I have my own so when you look at God
here and you have no explicit verse in
the Bible Old Testament or new testament
where Jesus clearly says I am God
rather every time God is mentioned in
the Old Testament or the New Testament
you see a reference to Jesus saying that
the one only God that that is one God so
that means it cannot be three
you cannot say the father is the God and
Jesus Is God and the Holy Ghost is God
and the father knew everything and Jesus
was on Earth and Holy Ghost was I don't
know going around top of evil and all
three are one and one is three we don't
find this in the Bible and this is why
even those verses and I'm not going to
get too technical here you can watch
some of our other channels videos on the
one message Foundation that reference
that trinitarians use have been shown to
be Fabrications that were put into the
Bible later on in the 9th century and
the earlier manuscripts don't have those
verses
so like for example for there are three
there bear record in heaven the Father
the Son of word exactly this is this is
the fabrication if you look at I have a
Greek Bible that shows you references to
earlier manuscripts you will find in
none of the early manuscripts you'll
find such a verse and that's why
trinitarians have kind of brought this
verse into the Bible and Unitarian
Christians will still today reject this
verse and many study Bibles will also
point out that these were later Editions
wow this is uh
it's just mind-blowing um but I'll
comment more after we get past these two
two more excellent two more to go
um the next one is going to be the fact
that Jesus peace and blessings be upon
himself reference that there is only one
true God Jesus in the Bible himself says
so this is eternal life that you may get
to know the one true God
and Jesus crime who Christ whom you sent
in the Bible according to Christians and
you can look up the verse you find that
Jesus says that there's there is only
one true Mighty almighty God and that
God sent Jesus
so now if I say Eddie you are the boss
you are the one who runs this show and
you can order me to go to another city
on your behalf and represent you or your
show right that clearly shows that
you're the boss you're in run you're the
only one and you are sending a separate
entity to represent you so when I find
in the Bible that Jesus is saying that
that they may get to know you the only
true God
and then separates himself from that
saying and Jesus Christ who you sent
that is very explicit to me that Jesus
is not God the one being sent is not the
sender exactly
and anybody with an open mind and an
open heart that looks at that verse will
come to the conclusion repeat that verse
one more time where Jesus Christ says
that this is eternal life that they may
get to know you the only true God and
Jesus Christ whom you sent sounds like
yes right so this is like saying the
this is like saying as a testimony of
faith of the Muslims that we bear
witness that there is only one worthy of
worship the only God worthy of worship
is Allah and the prophet of the time he
would pay testimony that he is a prophet
sent by God as today we would say the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him was the servant and messenger
of God and if me and you were in the
time of Jesus we would follow Jesus as
the prophet of that time that was the
Muslims of that time this is what brings
someone into the fold of Islam this
statement right there doesn't that
resemble so much
9 20 17 3 or yeah I don't know the top
of my head yeah this is something that's
so powerful because it sounds like the
shahada it does yes number one now this
is the number one reason why Jesus peace
be upon him who we love and will Revere
as one of the mightiest Messengers again
you can get yourself a not buy you can
get a free ticket to the Hellfire as a
Muslim If you deny or disrespect Jesus
or his mother very true so now clear
Lucid unambiguous proof that Jesus is
not the literal literal God Son of God I
want to give it to you in this one I
remember these verses really well even
though we didn't prep for this this is
all off the hook this is Dean show live
yeah
um the first is Matthew 21 19. and the
next is Mark 13 32 I believe I could be
wrong but yeah this is what I remember
where Jesus does not know in Matthew 21
19 Jesus sees if he's hungry first thing
how does God get hungry uh but he sees a
fig tree and not knowing if there's
fruit on it or not he goes to the Fig
Tree and he finds that there's no fruit
on it for it was not the season and then
he curses it
well the Bible tells us that God knows
everything
and if Jesus peace and blessings be upon
him we love him we respect him we
believe he was born of a miraculous
birth we believe he was a true Prophet
but if he didn't know that knowledge
that means he cannot be God you cannot
know everything and not know it's got to
be one or the other right Square soccer
remember that
and in Mark 13 32 I believe where Jesus
talks about the hour and he said nobody
knows of the hour
not even the angels nor the son but only
the father
and that's a very interesting verse
because here
if Jesus had not clarified according to
the Christian Bible nor the son they
could have said oh yeah but if he says
the father and the son is included but
this verse is very explicit
Mark 13 32 I believe where he says
nobody knows the hour the Reckoning when
Jesus is going to come back except he
clarifies not even the angels nor the
son
only the father so if Jesus according to
the Christian Bible peace and blessings
be upon Him clearly states that nobody
knows the hour he doesn't know nor the
son he says I don't know only God knows
then that means Jesus could not be God
if Christians come back and say hey but
he was on Earth and at that time he took
a human form okay then he wasn't God if
you didn't have the quality of being
all-knowing and according to the Bible
God knows everything and I believe in
you believe in anybody with any sense
would believe that God the creator of
universe knows everything
at the moment that he doesn't know the
hour or he doesn't know the Fig Tree
having fruit he cannot be gone
I am a firm believer that there is only
one God as Abraham Moses Jesus Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon all the
prophets taught this message that there
is only one God and that God sent
prophets he sent Messengers to remind
mankind out of his Mercy for the
guidance of mankind and none of those
prophets told their people to worship
them
rather they call to the worship of the
one Creator I believe Adam Abraham Moses
Jesus Muhammad peace and blessing be
upon all of them were true Messengers
righteous people who brought the message
of the one great Creator and they did
the will of that one great Creator they
were all Muslims they submitted
themselves to their creator I don't
believe any of them were God I don't
believe Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him as God I don't believe Jesus
peace and blessings upon me him or God
they all had Miracles different miracles
Moses split the sea Abraham lived and
fired didn't get hurt Jesus walked on
water Muhammad split the moon priests
and blessings be upon all of them
but those were Miracles granted by the
Creator to show the people that these
are true prophets after all this someone
listened to listens to this what did
they need like someone like you were
discussing something with you were
telling me about there were some of
these uh influencers YouTube influencers
or me uh what's the name we have we have
some discussions going on we have uh
snico and we're going to be is it called
he is uh somebody has a very strong
following and he seems like a very
open-minded person and we're going to be
having conversations with him we're
going to invite him to Islam and we hope
that he enters Islam so if someone like
snico watches this and we and he sees
the breakdown I mean this should clear
up any doubt who Jesus is Andrew Tate as
well you've had a conversation with him
yeah I want to send my message to him
and I hope people can forward this video
to him uh you know we are we are very
open to discussing Islam with you we
don't Don't Force our religion on
anybody Islam is not something that is
forced it's something that comes from
the heart but we do want to spread the
message to you you know think about what
we have said and if you're interested
reach out to me or to Eddie and we'd
love to be a means of you learning about
the true Message of Islam the message of
Peace the message of guidance the
message of that one Creator the same
message the one message that all the
prophets brought we also have young Don
we we wish good for him he's also
somebody that has a social media
presence what does they do
I think he does games he does some I
don't know videos I I don't I don't
watch a lot of social media personally
but I've had one conversation with him
and how'd that go
um you know we we presented some of the
fallacies of the Bible and Dawn two
young Don yes and he was unable to
defend the Bible yeah and unfortunately
it seems like he's taken to a uh you
know kind of becoming more islamophobic
than to learn some people who um they
get the injection you you know truth and
they get a little hostile sometimes why
is that you see that and all we do
because sometimes people instead of
wanting to learn the truth they just
want to defend whatever they have come
to believe and this is why again this is
invitation to Young Don and anybody else
let's have a conversation live we can do
it online we can do it offline instead
of just sitting by yourself and spewing
out whatever you want sit down let's
have a conversation and we'd love to
discuss Islam with any of them and give
them the true Message of Islam and the
rest is in the hands of Allah it depends
if they have true sincerity to find the
truth they will find it but the things
that we've mentioned from the Bible from
these points we want everybody and it
doesn't matter if you're famous or not
or if you're a YouTuber or if you're not
I want you to think about these things
your own instincts your own heart will
tell you that the great creator of the
universe the one that controls
everything the one that made everything
that made me and you that made
everything in the universe and whatever
we don't even know and see is not going
to be peeing on himself right he's not
going to be hungry he's not going to be
not knowing things that that's if you
are in that state then you're not the
creator of the universe you know humans
even prophets even Pious people have
needs human we get tired but Allah never
gets tired what does the Quran tells us
that Allah Slumber does not overtake him
he never gets busy from one thing unable
to handle another thing right humans
have these shortcomings so if somebody
has these shortcomings and they're not
God and the one that is God will not
have he will be all-knowing all-powerful
all
capable you know some things are beneath
his honor right because God is the most
high but he is all capable so if you say
somebody is tempted by the devil then
you know that's not God God can't get
tempted you know people get tempted but
not God right if somebody doesn't know
something then you know that's not God
if somebody's not capable then you know
that's not God we believe the great
Creator is above that we say in Islam in
the Quran
there is nothing that can even be drawn
to a comparison with The Creator with
Allah there's nothing we we don't say
God is a man we don't say he's a monkey
we don't say he has a wife and a child
and you know a girlfriend and then these
these are all human relations right
these are human ideas we believe the
creators above that what do we say about
God and this is the message I want
everybody to know we we believe in what
God has told us about himself that he is
one that that God is above he is he is
far above our imagination he is far
above us restricting him to being a
human being or an animal or a wood
carving or a statue he's above all that
he created everything he's always been
there he will always be there he is the
owner of the day of judgment he is the
one that the judgment is his that is God
that is the creator and that is the one
we want you to believe in that God that
Creator sent us Messengers and the true
message of those Messengers was that
there is only one God worshiped no idol
worship no human worship no saint
worship just that one God and follow the
prophet of your time doesn't that make
sense
I mean how could you say that the people
of Moses had no idea who Jesus was they
had no idea who the Holy Ghost was they
just knew God and they had to do good
deeds and they had to do all of that and
then Jesus comes peace and blessings be
upon him and then the whole game
switches the whole game switches up to
now you don't have to worry about good
the Salvation is free you just believe
in Jesus does that make sense
you know
I'm gonna
think back to my early days when I used
to go to church and I used to honestly
try to grasp the concept that the
preachers would be telling us
and they would tell us something they
would tell us that
Adam ate from the tree
and this was such a sin
that all children are born sinful they
are sinners right some Christians try to
switch that up today the sinful nature
but this is what we were taught is that
they are sinners
now think about that Eddie you have kids
right
imagine if you make a mistake let's say
you run a red light or something
could I go arrest your son for it I mean
just now that wouldn't which court in
the world would accept that it does that
right who does that if I if I
as Usman let's say I rob a bank may
Allah not make us do such things but
let's say I do
and a court comes and says that we're
going to arrest your son and and then
whenever you have a grandson he's going
to get arrested and your great grandson
they're all going to be felons they're
going to have felonies on their record
because of your crime they might do that
as some communist countries
wherever that's done I don't think any
Court I don't think even in a communist
country anybody would accept that as
Justice and we believe God is just and I
think all of you watching would believe
God is just
so
now in the Christian doctrine
Adam eating from the tree was such a sin
that all of mankind is born with the sin
they're born sinful
and how do you get rid of that sin
is God sends his son which is also
himself but it's his son
doesn't make sense there anyway
and then humans torture betray put a
thorn crown on his head and beat and and
and and crucify and kill God
or his son not sure which one
and that gets rid of the sin come on
that makes no sense he had me thinking
when you were saying who would do that
the reason I said communist country is
like when you have certain people let's
say in China and then they're coming out
and speaking of their story some kind of
truth then they go after their family
and whatnot yes that's true but think
about that but this is not you know who
would consider that Justice it's not
that's Injustice even in China if
somebody robs somebody yeah I cannot
imagine that the Chinese government
would say that not just that person not
his kids but every grandkid every child
forever that comes from that lineage is
all going to be criminals no no
nobody would consider that just now
think through this
if I think of it in the terms that I
understood growing up somebody goes into
a liquor store a store they're not
supposed to take something without
paying they take it they put in their
pocket they walk out Adam eating from
the tree yeah yeah and they come back as
Adam repented as Muslims we believe he
repented his repentance was accepted God
is all forgiving
but the Christian doctrine would have it
that he came back and he spoke to the
owner God he's the owner of everything
he said look I should have done it my
bad my mistake I want to repent
and God tells him you can't you're going
to be a sinner your children are going
to be arrested their children are going
to have their record you're going to be
born everybody's going to be born with
that crime on you unless my son which
somehow is the owner and his son but
anyway his son who is a perfect child
4.0 student all A's never disobeyed his
parents never did anything wrong never
broke perfect example I want you who
stole who did this wrong
to have your kids and her family come
and torture him and beat him and kill
him and then we're even Stephen
sense
you know I mean just forget the
indoctrination and and the and the
slogans and all of that just just think
through that does that make sense to you
how could killing God
get rid of sin
huh is God suicidal was this a suicide
mission it doesn't make any sense so if
Andrew Tate uh young Don what's the
other guy's name snico snico if any uh
so it's okay young Don is a Christian
yes
um Andrew Tate says he believes in God I
honestly don't believe even though he
throws up the Trinity but I honestly
don't believe he believes that but God
law knows best we just went over to
Trinity and everything so if he watches
this he can you know if he's sincere he
looked into it and and then uh the other
person um sneakos
uh not very religious he is kind of
learning and he seems very open-minded
and if he sees this this is an
invitation we hope to talk to him uh
we're not here to indoctrinate anybody
we're just here to answer questions and
share our message so we'd love to have a
conversation with him where we explain
Islam to him and answer his questions
without me being interrupted by Young
Don every few minutes uh we'd love to
have a conversation and we hope that
Allah opens his heart to the truth if um
look I don't know what kind of question
they'd ask but a lot of times people
will throw out some of the same random
questions that they've hurt others so
someone like Andrew Tate says look I
believe in God you know and I give to
the church and I love God I go to church
twice a week right so this is between me
and God what would you say to Andrew
Taylor my message to Andrew take there
would be that as you believe in God
that's the first step that's excellent
we also believe in God as Muslims but
what does that mean you believe in God
do you believe God has a son do you
believe God has a holy ghost do you
believe it's in three in one and if you
do think through that you know that God
is in three you know that this idea of
Eternity was developed over time that
wasn't the true message of Jesus you
know that the church is corrupt I mean I
don't have to explain it to you you've
lived in countries I think you know
better than me that this system is it
was a political system why could priests
not get married the Catholic Church the
Greek Orthodox church and the political
power that they developed through
different tactics these are ways of
corruption if you look if you go to
church and the way you worship just
think about that look at that and look
at the Bible is that the way Jesus
prayed do you go to church and put your
head on the ground and pray to the one
creator
think about The Message of Islam the
belief in one God the belief that Jesus
Muhammad Abraham Moses were all prophets
peace and blessings be upon them and
tell me doesn't that make sense and if
that does then don't worry about Society
don't worry about cancer culture don't
worry about anybody saying anything
believing that one God as that God has
revealed about himself that he is one
that he has no partners that he has no
children he's not born from anybody and
he nobody's born from him
if we think about this whole concept of
God having a child and then that being
him it doesn't make sense if Mary is the
mother of God how could God impregnate
his mother
does that make any sense to you any
sense Andrew Tate does that make sense
to you snico young Don does that make
sense to you it doesn't make sense snico
says look I'm young I got time to figure
this out
I would tell snico go to a graveyard and
this is a personal practice of mine I
don't tell people about it but I'm going
to share
occasionally by myself I go to the
graveyard and I look at those plaques in
the Muslim graveyards we don't have
tombs and things we have a plaque that
has the years the person lived and check
how many people younger than you are in
that graveyard we don't know how much
time we have on Earth there is no
guarantee that you're going to live to
see tomorrow but there is a guarantee
that death is coming
Allah tells us in the Quran that every
soul shall taste death that's a
guarantee how long you will live none of
us know how many of your friends have
already passed away I had friends that
were 14 15 16 that I buried in my
teenage days so don't put things off you
want to be right with God you want to be
on the right path of the true message
because that's the purpose of your
creation the purpose of life is to
recognize and worship your creator
so don't waste time when you know The
Message of Islam is the truth accept it
and it doesn't matter if you're not a
YouTuber and you're watching this video
and you're on that edge I want you to
take that leap of faith and and accept
Islam you know Islam is the truth you
can watch our videos you can learn about
the scientific Miracles the linguistic
Miracles the historic Miracles the
miracle the prophet peace be upon him we
have a video about the moon splitting
and me and you had done a show about it
but now it's time for you to accept
Islam don't put it off anymore you know
reach out to Eddie
would do your shahada on the show I know
accept Islam for your own salvation
Allah doesn't need anybody we need our
creator this is if you become the most
powerful Rich wealthy person in the
world but you don't know the purpose of
your creation you failed wow we got a
few more minutes I found have you seen
something really simple I usually tell
people you know give them this homework
if the and you believe that if they are
to put aside any intermediaries between
them and God they don't call upon anyone
other they're some people confused some
people you know what you're saying it
just kind of connect that if they're
sincere it's connecting with their logic
their mind their hearts this makes sense
to get out of the confusion
them calling on the Creator alone with
not calling on in the name of Jesus you
know if someone says I pray in the name
of Jesus you know what's wrong with that
but think about that how did Jesus pray
whose name did he pray in whose name did
Moses pray in whose name did Abraham
pray in look at the Bible who prayed in
the name of Jesus
I mean until Paul and the Pauline
Doctrine which was after that Paul asked
for those of you that may not know he
never met Jesus you know he claimed he
had a vision or whatever you could eat
some mushrooms and see your own Visions
I'm not worried about that but
if you look at Seoul which is Paul
before his becoming Christian he used to
persecute Christians if you look at the
earlier followers of Jesus they disputed
Paul they disagreed with him and today
your Christianity has been set up more
by Paul than Jesus wasn't he a early
Bounty Hunter he was he used to torture
kill fine
Massacre Christians and Jesus lived by
the religious quote of that time a
circumcision keeping the Sabbath and all
of that Paul did away with all that why
did he do away with it if it was to be
done Away With Jesus would have done
away with it peace and blessings be upon
him so I want you to go back and think
how did Jesus pray
you know I was in Tampa recently and and
I think there'll be a clip posted on our
Channel soon we had uh we were out with
some of the brothers after one of the
programs and this lady came and started
singing and dancing and yelling and
screaming and saying I pray in the name
of Jesus and in the name of Jesus let's
bust a dance move you know and I told
her look is that how Jesus prayed
is this what Jesus taught you peace and
blessings be upon him no
Jesus put his head on the ground and
prayed he didn't pray in the name of
Jesus Moses didn't pray in the name of
Jesus Abraham didn't pray in the name of
Jesus Moses Abraham Jesus Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him they prayed to
that one God so pray to that one God
directly put your head on the ground and
ask that God for guidance
everybody if you're not Muslim tonight
I want you to just pray to the one
Creator say oh the creator of the
universe the one who gave me life the
one that made the universe guide me to
the truth and open your heart and you
will see Islam is the only truth
whoa there's a lot to digest there but
we end with something very simple asking
the one created the heavens and earth
via B Andrew Tate uh snico young Don or
anyone who's listening can be a pastor a
preacher Christian you know anybody and
at the end of the day you know somebody
wants to continue on their ways I mean
we don't force Islam on anybody Islam is
not something that was forced by the
sword unlike if you look at South
America and you look at the Philippines
where the Spanish and others they they
forced Christianity on the people if you
look at history when when Palestine when
Jerusalem was ruled by the Muslims like
salahuddin ayubi Saladin as people say
and I just want people to be able to
understand you had churches you had
synagogues you had Muslims everybody was
allowed to Worship in their way whoever
wanted to accept Islam could when Spain
andalus was ruled by the Moors by the
Muslims they were Christians they were
Jews they were Muslims some people
converted themselves they reverted back
to the original faith of Islam some
people didn't they were allowed to live
when the Spanish Inquisition happened go
look it up history
the Christians that came with the
Inquisition they came with the sword and
they massacred and tortured anybody who
was Jewish Muslim or a different type of
Christian until they didn't leave
anybody except what they found to be
Christian in their way in Spain the
Spanish Inquisition Google it look it up
if you look at the Spaniards that came
to South America they destroyed the
native religions and languages and they
forced people into Catholicism not Islam
so we're not forcing anybody we're
bringing you a message a message of
Peace a message of guidance a message to
have inner peace and societal peace a
message of Islam a message of the one
Creator to believe in him as all the
messengers from Adam to Muhammad peace
and blessing be upon all of them the
message that they brought that's it and
just ending with that it reminded me of
a authentic statement from the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessed to be upon
him who is describing a house that's
missing one brick and people are going
around this house saying wow how
beautiful is it but there's one brick
missing he said I am that brick the last
of all the prophets the last of the
prophets and Messengers who was sent for
Andrew Tate yes snico and young Don and
for everybody else he's the messenger
for all of mankind till the end of time
till the end till the day of judgment
whoa this uh inshallah can be a benefit
fit for people who are seeking to know
the truth who are sincere you broke it
down top 10 reasons why Jesus is not God
Son of God but he's a mighty messenger
just like Abraham Moses and Prophet
Muhammad all of them brought the same
message worship the Creator not the
Christian thank you so much my pleasure
we say may Allah give you the best of
reward and we hope that everybody
watching uh will really take this
message and contemplate it and if you
haven't accepted Islam yet this is your
this is your chance this is not a
coincidence that you're watching this
video the God the Creator wrote for you
to watch it so don't waste this chance
thank you thank you shay thank you for
being with us and thank you for tuning
in I told you
you don't want to miss these exciting
episodes exciting guests so make sure
you subscribe right now hit that
notification Bell and we'll see you next
time and look
I have a surprise for you and I can't
leave you without a gift if you want to
read the book The Quran that goes over
the purpose of life while you're here
why you've been created talks about
Jesus and his Blessed Mother there's a
whole chapter named that for her
www.thedeenshow.com you get your free
copy of the Quran sent to you that's my
gift I'll give to you and we'll see you
next time make sure you support the dean
Center where we have the D show in it
and much much more we'll see you next
time until then the greetings of Jesus
and Muhammad and all the messengers
peace be with you assalamualaikum
um
foreign
would you like to be part of the first
ever Mega dawa Center in the U.S a 35
000 square foot former Church on a Four
Acre plot equipped with a Masjid a tower
center a TV recording studio a dow
outreach program and much much more over
the last decade one of the most
successful and consistent dawa Series
has been the dean show and now we want
to help our brother Eddie take it to the
next level from the dean show to the
dean Center inshallah where it's going
to be this Mega dawa Center in Florida
and we need your help doing so so please
my brothers and sisters donate today
with whatever you can and share the hail
share this link with everyone you know
because everyone who donates through you
sharing the link you're going to get
part of the reward as well which is